final fantasy xiv's latest expansion and
walkers almost here releasing on
november 23rd or the 19th if you're a
fan of early access it's set to finish
up a massive storyline spanning over 10
years and is the game's fourth expansion
after the reworked a realm reborn i got
invited to a preview event being held to
get some hands-on time with the new
reaper and sage jobs and of course it's
important to note that everything here
that i'm talking about is based off an
in development build final fantasy 14
and walker and any content is subject to
change before we actually get our hands
on the final version of the expansion
the event itself was set up to let us
run around and test jobs both new and
old while doing fates and hunts and two
new zones garlemald and thavnir old
charlene was also available as for us to
explore and meet up with people to run
the tower of zot the one dungeon that
was available in the preview build
while i didn't find any hunts i did run
the dungeon multiple times with a few
people on a few different jobs also
while trying out the new and improved
truss system also spent a good amount of
time with target dummies on a very
scenic beach in that near just trying
out jobs that i wanted to see the
changes that they made too i feel like
it's important to let you know that i'm
a tank mate at heart i spent most of my
time playing reaper and i do have
impressions for sage as well but healing
really isn't my strongest suit i didn't
even get to take the sage into a dungeon
run for example also i'm not going to be
getting super technical in my breakdown
at all all of these numbers and the math
on the skills as we were presented them
could change anyways so i'm going to
just focus mainly on how the jobs felt
to play i feel like that this is more
important than just the numbers
after getting my hands on both of the
new jobs my biggest takeaway was how
much they both feel fresh and different
in terms of both style and how they play
stage even more so given that it has to
fall under this new healer split of pure
healers and shield healers reaper even
does a lot to stand out against most of
the other physical melee jobs with its
multiple meters and keeping track of
weaving scythe attacks and avatar
attacks both jobs are very flashy and i
feel they are a great showcase of how
far the game has come both in terms of
design visually and mechanically they
both offer something that feels familiar
to fans of their specific roles but have
enough job specific identity to make the
overall experience of using them stand
out as a fun and enjoyable one overall i
feel they're excellent additions to the
existing jobs in the game and i cannot
wait to play them more once the
expansion is finally in my hands
i know i already talked a bit about how
much i'm not the biggest fan of healing
but my first reaction after messing
around with the skills for sage was that
i may have to change that everything
from the gundam inspired weapon design
to the wild and flashy animations even
the sound effects going off constantly
sound like they could be ripped right
out of the future
[Music]
they all come together to make this
really rad feeling here that plays
differently from all the other ones i
have experience with being able to mark
a party member with the cardia skill so
that they are passively receiving heals
while i'm getting carried away shooting
laser beams everywhere is exactly what
i'm looking for of course i want to make
sure my friends stay alive but i also
want to look good while i'm doing it and
that's exactly what it feels like the
sage is giving me they also have this
really cool gap closing ability called
icarus that can be used to propel
yourself towards enemies and allies
alike i'll probably end up using this
too much just because of how sick it
looks overall though i think my favorite
sage ability is and please forgive my
pronunciation of this eucrazia it
augments three of your abilities to be
more powerful versions of themselves in
other words it makes my existing lasers
into even bigger lasers and honestly who
doesn't want that my time with stage
left me wanting more and maybe even
considering spending more time in the
healing role itself even with the
anxiety that the responsibility gives me
final fantasy 14 did help me get over my
tank anxiety after all and it would make
sense that it would also probably do the
same for healing and if that isn't a
great endorsement of a new job i really
don't know what is reaper's a job i
spent most of my time with during the
preview event and the first time that i
got in shroud to proc and i became
enshrouded or as i like to endearingly
call it shifting into bad boy mode since
it visually changes your normally cheery
warrior of light into an angry red-eyed
shadow of the hedgehog void scent
version of yourself i knew i had a new
favorite melee dps job everything you
can do on reaper just feels so dang
badass the sick factor isn't even
limited to living out your dream of
being a scythe-wielding hot-topic-fueled
nightmare creature the feeling of
weaving your way through the reaper's
various abilities to get into that bad
boy mode just feels great
around all the core attacks you have
this really fun toolkit that also allows
you to do all sorts of fun stuff like
dash and teleport as well
[Music]
the thing that i really like the most
was just how awesome the reaper looks in
motion all of your attacks have these
really cool red or blue tearing effects
that follow your scythe movements and
they'll change depending on whatever
ability you're using this effect is only
amplified when you actually shift into
bad boy mode and go absolutely crazy
slashing everywhere where your warrior
of light is completely surrounded by
twice as many of these bright red and
black colored tears while you're
whipping your scythe around wildly and i
just love every second of it reaper is
kind of a natural step for me too since
my current favorite melee dps class is
dragoon and while they still kind of
function a little differently i think
there's enough to kind of bridge that
gap they also ended up sharing the same
armor too so i already have a really
nice back catalog of cool glamours to
use already and that's the most
important thing my love and loyalty to
tanking ultimately means that i don't
think i'll be switching over to being a
reaper main but you bet this is one of
the first alt jobs i'm going to level up
it could very easily be my second
favorite job i've played even with the
few hours i've had to learn it there's
still so much more of end walker for me
to see even with what little i had i
still wanted to try out so many other
jobs and do so many other things i
wanted to explore more of the great
desolate ruins of garland mold i wanted
to just sit and vibe on the beach in the
avenue for a while longer and take in
that amazing soundtrack some more
because man that new end walker motif is
so so good
[Music]
i can already feel it pulling on my
emotions even without the memories or
scenes attached to them but sadly
there's not enough time nevertheless i
still played enough to get me
exceedingly stoked for the adventure
that we're all going to be going on
together once end walker finally drops
buckle up fellow warriors of light we've
got a god to kill and a story to wrap up
and i hope to see you there for those
we've lost and for those we've yet to
save oh if you do see an extremely
handsome rogan named phil pwiskin and
the party finder say hi i promise i'll
do my best to tank the dungeon for you
also if you've made it this far and you
enjoyed what you've watched please leave
a like and a comment if you do they
might let me make more final fantasy
stuff between you and me that's exactly
what i want to do
[Music]
you